Over 1300 years ago, on today's date,
May 28th, in the year 722, a tiny
kingdom was born in and led to the
liberation of Spain from Islamic
occupation. To appreciate its
significance, we must travel back a
decade earlier to 7-Eleven when Muslims
godlessly invaded Spain to destroy it.
To quote from the chronicle of 754, once
on European soil, they, the chronicle
continues, ruined beautiful cities,
burning them with fire, condemned lords
and powerful men to the cross, and
butchered youths and infants with the
sword. The Muslims met and beat Spain's
Visigothic nobles at the pivotal battle
of Gualete. According to the Muslim
chronicler Elhakam, never was there in
the West a more bloody battle than this,
for the Muslims did not withdraw their
scimitars from them, from the Christians
for 3 days. The Muslim invaders
continued to penetrate northward into
Spain, not passing a place, continues
Alakan, without reducing it and getting
possession of its wealth. For Allah
Almighty had struck with terror the
hearts of the infidels. Such terrorism
was intentionally cultivated in keeping
with the Quran. C351 or 812 for
examples. For instance, the invaders
slaughtered, cooked, and pretended to
eat Christian captives. Then they
intentionally released other Christians
who horrified fled back to their
kinsmen. According to another Muslim
historian, El Makari, these released
captives quote inform the people of
Spain that the Muslims feed on human
flesh, thereby contributing in no small
degree to increase the panic of the
infidels. Contrary to the claim that
Spain capituated easily or that the
Spaniards reasoned that Muslim rule was
no worse and possibly more lenient than
that of the Visigoths, which many modern
academics claim, even Muslim chronicers
such as Alakari note how, quote, "The
Christians defended themselves with the
utmost vigor and resolution, and great
was the havoc that they made among the
ranks of the faithful, that is among the
Muslims." In Cordoba, for example, a
number of leading Visigoths and their
people hold themselves up in a church.
Although quote, "The besieged had no
hopes of deliverance, they were so
obstinate that when safety was offered
to them on condition either of embracing
Islam or paying Jiza, they refused to
surrender and the church being set on
fire, they all perished in the flames."
Continues adding that the ruins of this
church became a place of great
veneration for later generations of
Spaniards because quote the courage and
endurance displayed in the cause of
their religion by the people who died in
it. In the end, native Spaniards had two
choices. Acquious to Muslim rule or
quote, "Flee to the mountains where they
risked hunger and various forms of
death." According to an early Christian
chronicler, "Enter Pelagius, better
known as Paleo, a relative of and
swordbearer to the last king Rodrik, who
died at Guadalete. After that battle,
Paleo retreated north, where Muslim rule
was still tenuous. Eventually, however,
he consented to become a vassel of one
Munaza, a local Muslim chief. Through
some strategy, Monaza married Paleo's
sister, a matter that the swordbearer
was by no means agreeable to. Having
expressed displeasure at the seizure of
his sister and having ceased paying Jiza
tribute, Muslims were sent to apprehend
him treacherously and bring him back
bound in chains. Unable to fight the
Muslims coming for him because they were
so numerous, Paleo quote climbed a
mountain and joined himself to as many
people as he found, hastening to
assemble. These are all quotes from the
chronicle of Alonso III. There in the
deepest recesses of the Atorian
mountains, the only free spot left in
the Iberian Peninsula, the assembled
Christian fugitives declared Paleo their
new king. Thus was born the kingdom of
Atorias, the only free and independent
Christian region in all of Spain.
Hearing this, the king or the Muslim
governor of Cordoba, moved by an insane
fury, writes the early Christian
chronicler, ordered a very large army
from all over Spain to go forth and
bring the infidel rebels to heal. The
massive Muslim army surrounded Paleo's
mountain. They sent Oppa, a bishop or a
nobleman who like many other Christians
had acquiesed to Muslim rule to reason
with Paleo at the mountain of a deep
cavern. Oah once he had met Paleo said
the following to him. Quote, "If when
the entire army of the Goths was
assembled, it was unable to sustain the
attack of the Ishelites at the battle of
Guadalete, how much better will you,
Paleo, be able to defend yourself on
this mountaintop? To me, it seems
difficult. Rather, heed my warning and
recall your soul from this decision so
that you may take advantage of many good
things and enjoy the partnership of the
Arabs. Paleo's response, quote, I will
not associate with the Arabs in
friendship, nor will I submit to their
authority. Then, the rebel made a
prophecy that would be fulfilled over
the course of nearly eight centuries.
Quote, "Have you not read in the divine
scriptures that the church of God is
compared to a mustard seed and that it
will be raised up again through divine
mercy?" Opa affirmed that it was so,
continues the fugitive, quote, "Christ
is our hope that through this little
mountain, which you see, the well-being
of Spain and the army of the Gothic
people will be restored. Now, therefore,
trusting in the mercy of Jesus Christ, I
despise this multitude and am not afraid
of it. As for the battle with which you
threaten us, we have for ourselves an
advocate in the presence of the Father,
that is the Lord Jesus Christ, who is
capable of liberating us from these
few."
There at Kovadanga, meaning the cavern
of the Lady, battle commenced. On
today's date, May 28th, in the year 722,
a shower of rocks rained down on the
Muslims in the narrow passes, where
their numbers counted for nothing and
only caused confusion. Afterward, Paleo
and his band of rebels rushed forth from
their caves and hiding places and made
great slaughter among them. Those who
fled the carnage were tracked and mowed
down by other now emboldened
mountaineers. In the words of one 19th
century historian, quote, "A decisive
blow was dealt at the Moish power. The
advancing tide of conquest was stemmed.
The Spaniards gathered heart and hope in
their darkest hour, and the dream of
Muslim invincibility was broken."
Several subsequent Muslim attempts,
including three major campaigns, were
made to conquer the newborn kingdom of
Atoria. And the Christians, quote, of
the north scarcely knew the meaning of
repose, security, or any of the
amenities, writes historian Lewis
Bertrand. Constant jihad raids created a
wild frontier zone roughly along the
Dwero River which the Muslims called the
great desert. It became a quote
territory where a Muslim fights for the
faith as one medieval Muslim wrote or as
the great Kaldun affirmed every Muslim
ruler of Enolucio is obligated to quote
wage the jihad himself and with his
armies at least once a year. Lewis
Bertrand offers a good summary of what
happened during that. He writes, quote,
"To keep the northern Christians in
their place, it did not suffice to
surround them with a zone of famine and
destruction, it was necessary also to go
and sow terror and massacre among them.
Twice a year in the spring and autumn,
an an army sied forth from Cordoba to go
and raid the Christians, destroy the v
their villages, their fortified posts,
their monasteries, and their churches.
Except when it was a question of
expeditions of larger scope involving
sieges and pitched battles. In cases of
simply punitive expeditions, the
soldiers of the khif confined themselves
to destroying harvests and cutting down
trees. If one bears in mind that this
brigandage was almost continual and that
this fury of destruction and
extermination was regarded as a work of
piety. It was after all a holy war
against infidels, it is not surprising
that whole regions of Spain should have
been made
iriably sterile. This was one of the
capital causes of the deforestation from
which the peninsula still suffers. With
what savage satisfaction and in what
pious accents do the Arab analysts tell
us of those at least by annual rage? A
typical phrase for praising the devotion
of a khalif is this quote he penetrated
into Christian territory where he
wrought devastation devoted himself to
pillage and brought and brought many
prisoners. At the same time as they were
devastated whole regions were
depopulated. The prolonged presence of
the Muslims therefore was a calamity for
this unhappy country of Spain. By their
system of continual raids, they kept her
for centuries in a condition of
brigandage and
devastation. Even so, the mustard seed
would not die. A vital spark was still
alive, writes Edward Gibbon. Some
invincible fugitives preferred a life of
poverty and freedom in the Atorian
valleys. The hearty mountaineers
repulsed the slaves of the Khif.
Moreover, according to historian Henry
Edward Watts, quote, "All who were
dissatisfied with Moorish dominion, all
who clung to the hope of a Christian
revival, all who detested Muhammad fled
to the tiny Christian kingdom in the
mountains of Atoria." Over the following
centuries, the mustard seed grew to the
point of engulfing the entire northwest
of the peninsula. It persevered. Various
kingdoms whose core identity revolved
around Christian defiance to Islam
evolved from or alongside the mustard
seed. They would soon launch the
reconista, the great reconquest and
reclamation of the Spain from Islam.
Century after century, the Christians
slowly managed to advance southward,
liberating one formerly Christian city
after another from Muslim rule until
1492 when the last Muslim held region in
Spain, Granada, was liberated. And it
all came to pass thanks to Paleo's
Atorian mustard seed planted over 800
years ago on this day at the battle of
Kovadanga.